hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused channel and my name is Paul
today's video is the second installment
in the series mystery languages if you
haven't seen the first video in the
mystery language a series you can check
it out right here but basically this is
how it works I will play you an audio
sample of a language and then I'll show
you a visual sample of the language in
its written form and you can guess what
language it is but whether you guess
correctly or not that doesn't matter
the important thing is that you leave
your guesses and the reasons for your
guesses in the comments down below and
that will spark some interesting
discussion so let's get right into the
first language please listen I'm bidding
on you tamil kanaka dogs a Miss Emily
piyo namida wa upon voila kena mohkumat
me - oh la mancha la CIMA can do Oh
bugaboo Chaparro suppose away Nami
Ursula I'm not bidding and who loses and
peanut bucket - manga body upon
remarkable akka Omaha Bondy okay Lions
are gonna boot me to vanilla now let's
have a look at a few written samples of
that same language market among Nemo
Nina Harlan Co Tori Brad please not call
me that so what language do you think it
is the language is Cebuano a language
spoken on the island of Cebu in the
Philippines if you guessed Tagalog or
Filipino which is the official language
which is based on Tagalog then that's a
pretty good guess because Tagalog and
cebuano are closely related languages
I've studied Tagalog and I'm fairly
familiar with it and when I look at
Cebuano sometimes I don't know if I'm
looking at Tagalog with lots of
vocabulary I don't know or whether I'm
looking at say guano cebuano is
sometimes referred to as B Saye which is
actually a group of closely related
languages that are spoken in the Visayas
region in the Philippines but some
people like to refer to all the Bisaya
languages as a single language with
different dialects that's because all
the Bisaya languages are quite closely
related but also because well there's
power in numbers you may have noticed
the Spanish vocabulary in the sample
sentences that's because cebuano has
lots of Spanish loanwords just like
Tagalog does in fact zebra one has even
more Spanish loanwords than Tagalog okay
on to the second language please listen
consider an encounter connection food
when hyssop admin console has support T
home at a time hands on someone have
some making me meet han hong man
Yokohama de bunda come come in soon come
back home dry food Han come on kompis
only I put him to a but he can t see it
home half a dozen but you are now how
warm up so me and again let's have a
look at some written samples human
friend allow onion they somewhat it Lyon
I need to make appeal am so what
language is it
[Music]
it's the lao language flowers a language
spoken in the Southeast Asian nation of
Laos it's a member of the Tai kadai
language family which is spoken in some
parts of Southeast Asia southern China
and northern India if you thought the
language was tied then you were very
close because Thai and Lao are very
closely related and to a large degree
they are mutually intelligible they are
both tonal languages but one notable
difference is that ty has five tones
while Lao has six tones they're also
written in a slightly different script
but the scripts themselves are also
closely related and if you can read one
than reading the other shouldn't be too
hard
some of you may have noticed the tones
in the language samples which make the
language sound kind of melodic and you
might have guessed one of the Chinese
languages like Mandarin or Cantonese and
those guesses would make sense because
those are tonal languages just like Lao
and Thai are okay on to the third
language
please listen in Japan for the Xin
Romagna Marilla Magazine opera burrito
felt especially pentru Marfa Dez's on
Jerusalem arrhenius central mold in
Capitola now first ie alt FM a new my
Putin is MacArthur second O'Connor
possibly in part young skin we mix as a
cootie interrupted the longan drum
clubbed in Varsho via DJ Lika is taboo
Nakata the shop today she trade an
suerte popular and Randall clobberella
and again let's see a bit of the
language visually SCU's at SEMA butit's
repeated virag or singular limba new
orange any geodata lasats iman pachi
so what language is it
it's the Romanian language if you speak
any Romance languages that you probably
noticed right away that there was a lot
of Romance vocabulary in the samples but
the pronunciation might have seemed kind
of unusual to you
that's because Romanian is a Romance
language with some Slavic influence that
influence affects the pronunciation and
also the vocabulary of the language you
may have also noticed the little glyphs
above the letter A and below the letter
T those glyphs are actually an integral
part of those letters and those letters
along with this this and this give you a
quick hint that you're looking at
Romanian and not at a different Romance
language Romanian is spoken in romania
and moldova and is geographically
isolated from the other major Romance
languages the Slavic influence on the
language makes it distinct from the
other Romance languages but Romanian is
also said to be the closest Romance
language to the original Latin in
grammar that's probably true but in some
other areas like phonology it may not be
as close to the original Latin as say
Italian well I hope you enjoyed guessing
today's mystery languages leave your
guesses and your reasons in the comments
down below and also let me know if you
like this series and you think I should
continue doing it and again I want to
say thank you to all of my patreon
supporters for your continued support
especially these ones right here on the
screen for they're especially generous
pledges thank you for watching and have
a nice day
[Music]